there will be no spoilers in this
reaction review video just so everyone
knows up front no spoilers but I will
say that all of Star Wars was in this
film
Oh Disney don't do it hi everyone my
name is Tamra chambers and this is Tara
Jessa and last night I went and saw
infinity war I think the best part of
the movie is when Harry Potter showed up
probably the best part was when
Wolverine killed Star Trek Josie and the
Pussycat Doll slaughtered middle-earth
this had a lot going on and because this
has been 10 years in the making all
these different evolving styles for
Marvel there was a lot of different
themes and a lot of different
personalities to capture and it was a
lot I don't know that it could have been
done any better than it was because it
was like 90% spot-on there were a few
points where it was a little awkward or
a little like unbalanced but for the
most part everyone got their time
everyone was represented and this is
gonna be a film that fans really really
enjoy I know that I really enjoyed it I
don't really read individual comics
anymore if I you know I get a full
collection and just kind of binge that
way but growing up I read all the comics
I could get my hands on my dad when I
was younger like way younger asked me
what I wanted him to put my money into
stock wise and we we decided that we
were gonna buy stock and Marvel I have
always loved Marvel I have in my mind a
very clear image of young Tamara going
in and seeing the first Tobey Maguire
spider-man movie and it changing my life
and growing through these characters
even all the changes especially the
spider-man but growing through all these
characters and the different kind of
just evolutions that Marvel has made has
been so interesting and crucial and
that's why we're still there I think
Marvel has really made some strides
especially with guardians especially
with this new revamped hilarious Thor
especially with Wakanda and Black
Panther I think that those were crucial
evolutions for Marvel to make for them
to continue on to grow
and so thankfully those are there but
that being said there was a lot of
different clashing personalities to put
into this movie I felt like they all got
a good moment to really shine and do
their thing I didn't feel like it was
just all Captain America and Tony Stark
I even grew to love characters that I
hadn't previously loved before vision
and Scarlet Witch we're always just kind
of like bad they're just really powerful
and I don't have that much interest and
like their relationship but my god I
left being like I want to see way more
of them which how did they do that and
this this movie jam-packed with everyone
and I think how they did it was they
were really wise about the groups that
everyone was in it wasn't like a
50-person team just like having added at
Santos the whole time it was groups of
different teams kind of like really well
paired together and that was definitely
a smart move because you got some some
really good personalities that worked
well together that you had never seen
together though that is where my biggest
problem lies I had a hard time with the
Guardians group especially they have
such a specific comedy and a specific
attitude and tone and Chris Pratt
especially for me felt wrong in the film
not his acting or his character but I
kind of his character his character felt
out of place a lot of times one crucial
moment which when you see the film you
will know or if you have you will know
but even in some things between like him
and Thor and like you know him
interacting with other characters felt
very like ah at a place I guess that's
my one complaint I also didn't think
that Gamora was very well represented in
the film and I think I could agree with
me just skims the surface at the camera
hey bud so that's my kind of problem
with the film and kind of just my
overall like thoughts of how well
everyone meshed but as you've seen in
the trailer the film is about Thanos
Thanos Thanos
famous Damus the film is about Thanos
trying to get all six of the Infinity
stones for his infinity glove and
there's not much beyond that it's just
him getting the stones and every single
other person ever created trying to stop
him this villain feels so right I cannot
believe how much I enjoyed him I cannot
believe how much I liked the CGI I
cannot believe how much I liked his
power the fear he brought out and also I
felt myself like feeling for him there
were moments of softness within him
where you're like well you know you
still can't do the bad thing that you're
trying to do but all right the only
thing I didn't love about Thanos is his
motive it's like very mad man ESCA very
just like you're insane and obviously
obviously you are like of course your
Thanos duh I don't know I feel like it
could have been amped up a little bit
the motives for Thanos but I really
can't complain because I really enjoyed
him I enjoyed him more than I thought I
would I don't love a lot of the Marvel
super villains
except for Black Panther I know he
wasn't really a super villain but Dan
was he good
I just don't some of the villains in
Marvel just don't really do it for me
like here and here you know I think that
the characters in this film because
there were so many would have torn this
film apart if there wasn't a strong
center villain and so that was really
well done
okay so I have to own up to something
though the movie opened and I just went
I still haven't seen Doctor Strange
that's the only one I haven't seen is
Doctor Strange and he is in this quite a
bit as is everyone but I didn't feel
like I had missed anything but I will be
spending tonight after editing watching
Doctor Strange
cuz it's on Netflix come on damn ray
and I loved it and also The Avengers
movies aren't my favorite of the movies
I much prefer the single character films
even when you've got someone popping in
like in thor ragnarok recently you had
Thor Thor Thor in there and it was
amazing and it definitely made it better
to have the friends in there and that's
why it's so great to have this universe
so built up that like can you imagine
watching the first Iron Man movie that
came out in 2008 I think
can you imagine watching that and then
like seeing this right after him be like
that is where we got to from there nuts
we're like crazy that is nuts
that's nuts it's nuts it's nuts there's
a raccoon there's a raccoon and he
speaks this is the world we live in but
that being said like I said the Avengers
movies aren't always my absolute
favorites they're fun to watch because
it's fun to see everyone interact but
that's kind of where it ends but this
movie was just the bringing together of
ten years of amazing content really good
content that a lot of us have like grown
up watching everyone has so because
we've all grown that time but it's just
this was so good and and you can be
worried about the kind of element of
like oh is it just like a cash grab or
is it just like to see everybody on
screen and and it doesn't feel that way
I didn't get that vibe at least it felt
less of that and more of like alright
we've been working towards this and we
did it and I have to say I left the
theater feeling like destroyed but also
feeling like hah okay
we did it okay this note is so good
holy there is a moment before a big
fight in Wakanda that had my entire body
covered in goose bumps also at the end
of the film I got up and my knees were
hurting it I've never
had hurt knees and I realized this
because I was sitting in such tension
the whole time I was just like you know
frantically writing things down I said I
love the comedy I hate the destruction I
only half peed I had to pee really bad
and I went and I didn't want to miss
anything so I only half peed and then I
came back I was like I'll just deal with
this later
oh man do I recommend this film yes I
recommend seeing this film a million
times
also please no spoilers in the comments
that's where I've seen the most spoilers
at all since seeing the film I didn't
have anything spoiled for me before
seeing it and it was so much better that
way so please no spoilers in the
comments and if you haven't seen the
film maybe just don't go into the
comments just as a general rule but
especially for this I am gonna be
putting up a spoiler and theory video on
this movie on my personal channel so
check that out if you have any interest
in that I have quite a lot of theories
for this movie that I cannot wait to
talk about so thank you so so much for
watching you guys I will see you all
next week
[Music]